hello everyone and welcome to Game
fourteen of the 1972 World Chess
Championship match between Robert James
Fischer and Boris positive its passkey
now as you've seen in game 13 it was a
game that should not have ended in Boris
Spassky losing the game but as you see
in the quote above the board something
Boris said after the game he shook
Fisher's hands he congratulated Fischer
on his victory Fischer left and then
Spassky said that
how can one lose with the opponent's
only rook locked in completely something
legalish mentions in his book it's
really hard to understand how can you
such a game but it did happen
Fischer is again three points in the
lead and it will be very hard for
Spassky to get back into this game aside
from the games Fischer is still having a
pretty big war with the cameras even
though the camera crew left mr. Chester
Fox is a crew I was no longer in Iceland
but mr. Barry Fredrik the person who was
negotiating all of the deals for mr.
Chester Fox's company said that he will
lose a lot of money and he was looking
for ways to sue Fischer in considering
the the law in Iceland and Fischer's
attorney mr. Paul Marshall I said that
that there's really no way that can
happen and that even as he said that he
said that who he will be down a million
and two hundred something thousand
that's how much he he could make with
the television right but he said that
even if he somehow could sue Fischer for
this there's no way Fischer would ever
give him this money so there's a really
no point in doing it but he also said
that Fischer was not against cameras
that Fischer actually wanted cameras and
Fischer wanted this epic match to be
recorded but as Fischer said he wanted
he wanted the remote cameras to be
installed in the walls and in the roofs
of the playing hall and that they should
be controlled remotely from the outside
that there doesn't have to be a
cameraman inside the plane hold that
this is not some kind of a sports event
where you know there are a lot of
players moving and
the cameraman has to keep moving as well
so Fisher said that he in fact wanted
everything to be recorded just not the
way that they are doing it now also an
interesting fact Larisa Boris's wife
also came to Reykjavik and all of the
other wives of spassky ii came to
Reykjavik as well but they were staying
in the Soviet embassy they were not they
will not interfere with the match so
that being said let's let's see what
Bobby has installed for Spassky with the
white pieces in game 14 so it seems that
in this match Fischer decided to play
not so much of a force so again he opens
with c4 we have e six again a timid
approached by Spassky nice to have 3d 5
B 4 and Knight to f6 so the Queens
gambit declined is on the board nice the
c3 Bishop to e7 and here we have Bishop
f4 instead of Bishop to g5 in the two
previous games Bishop to g5 was played
but now comes the Bishop to f4 here
there was a game in 1969 between
Petrosyan and Spassky where c5 was
played and after D captures on c5 nice
to a6
it was a game eight of the Petrosyan
Spassky watch a championship match so
obviously a Fisher knows of this game so
instead after this Bishop to f4 a spots
key decides to go for castles we have
III by Fischer and now c5 a very
principled idea from Spassky as the
bishop is now an f4 instead of on g5 the
Bishop is not actively participating in
the fight over the central squares if
the Bishop wasn't g5 he would be
attacking the knight and the knight is
controlling one of the central squares
so by being on f4 it's not really
doesn't have really have any influence
on the center of the board
so c5 also b6 was played by Spassky in
1968 in Palma de américa tournament
against the Larsen but most likely
Fisher knows of this game as well so c5
now D captors on c5 we have Knight to c6
and now seek after Sunday 5 and oke
captors on d5 Bishop to e2 by Fischer
and Bishop characters uncie
five recapturing in the pond we have
castles and now comes East six if you
think a d4 would have been a very nice
central breakthrough here it does seem
like an interesting idea but as posses
Bishop on c5 is young unguarded so nice
play for would put black in a lot of
problems here you have to do something
about the Bishop Bishop to b6 and I can
simply capture it pawn characters and
now after Knight captures here you just
win a pawn captures captures and white
is up a pawn and blacks pawn structure
is a bit messed up so after this castles
Bishop to e6 by Spassky we have looked
to see one Fischer develops the rook
Spassky does the same rook to see it and
here we have a three by Fischer it would
be a bit premature as her Fischer is a
kind of x-raying this Bishop on c5 but
there is no good way to take advantage
of it because now for example Knight
captures on d5 does not win you a pawn
with the idea that if captures then
captures because Queen captures and
after Queen captures Knight captures
here rock captors on c5 it does seem
like you've won a phone but a pawn but
not really Knight captures on f4 we have
a captures on f4 and now comes the
Knights to d4 and this is the problem
you've opened up a discovered attack
against this rook here and also you are
attacking the unguarded bishop on e - so
this Bishop on e2 is really the problem
so here if you capture them first you
capture the bishop with check King has
to move and only now do you recapture
and now you are up a piece on the other
hand after Knight to d4 your best bet
would be Knight capture son before but
now simply rook captures and c5 and
black is now up the exchange and with a
much better position
so instead official goes a3 and okay we
have h 6 by Spassky now comes Bishop to
g3 a very important move now black will
not have that maneuver and Knight here
captures Bishop and then also attacking
the bishop on e2 so now the bishop is
very safe here and now Fischer has
Spassky has to react to this Bishop
being eyed by the rook
so Bishop goes back and now while the
bishop is here it's no longer on garden
and c5 now Fischer is definitely Espace
Keyes definitely threat
the push d4 we have Knights the ephah
official wants to exchange as many
pieces as he can and then the central
breakthrough will not be all that
significant
we have Knights the e7 by spots key
Spassky is looking to attack Fischer's a
very strong bishop on g3 either via
Knights to a5 or if forever decides to
move his knight then also Knight e4 will
be able to capture on g3 and further
does go for this he goes for this knife
to a four wing maneuver going after
spots past this dark square Bishop and
Spassky goes Knight to e4 a nice central
response to this wing maneuver by
Fischer rook captures and c8 Bishop
captures on c8 not allowing Queen
captures and then the knight capturing
the bishop would mess up black's pawn
structure and now comes Bishop to f3 a
very nice move by Fischer he wants to
keep an eye on this d4 square that
should remain blockaded
but although Bishop to h4 was also a
very nice idea but okay we have Knight
to f3 and now comes a push up to d7
attacking Fisher's knight and a 4 and
here it seems that the best bet for
fisheries captures on b6 and after Queen
captures then only then play Knight to
e5 and it seems like white is white is
doing okay here but here instead Fischer
goes Bishop to e5 and Spassky takes this
opportunity to eliminate the night
Bishop captures on a4 we have Queen
captures on e4 and now comes Knight to
c6 attacking the bishop on e5 and Bishop
back to f4 rush up to d4 doesn't really
do anything
simply Knight captures and after Knight
captures Queen to d6 and the black is
perfectly fine so Fisher goes Bishop
platform going back with the bishop
Queen to have sex a very nice
developing move by the Queen now the
Queen I will be very influential on the
King side and also on the Queen side and
here now Fischer could go for something
like Queen to c2 to defend the pawn here
but then spassky's idea was g5 and this
would be very dangerous for Fischer rush
up to G 3 H 4 is coming a very very nice
attack by by the world champion it would
occur here so here a Fisher had a
different idea
he thought this would perhaps be too
much so he went for better
to b5 but this does not work and this is
why it doesn't work
here's Spassky grabs upon Quinn capture
some be to replace Bishop captures on c6
and here Fischer thought that he would
simply win back the pawn but here's the
problem Spassky plays Knight to c3
and now you can't wait for Spassky to
capture the bishop so you would
recapture here you would have to you
have to figure out what to do with the
Queen and there really isn't a good
square you could think about doing
something like Bishop to e5 and then
after captures you can capture here B
captures and c6 and then simply move the
bishop but still black would have a much
better endgame with with such a such a
huge pawn majority here on the Queen
side so after Knight to c3 attacking
Fischer's Queen Queen to b4 was played
by Fisher we have Queen capture son B
for a capture son before and now be
Capra's on c6 there's really no point in
playing something like the 92 check to
mess up White's pawn structure on the
King side after King to h1 you'd much
rather fix your pawn structure here on
the Queen side because well white will
capture on b7 so this is definitely
better be captures on c6 we had Bishop
to e5 and then out comes Knight to be
five by Spassky now getting the knight
out of the way rook to c1 by Fischer and
here of a most valuable temple for black
would be f6 getting this Bishop out of
the way and only then deciding where to
develop the rook but here
Spassky point for the immediate look to
c8 and Fisher went Knight the d4 Fischer
is hoping to get some endgame where he
can hold this position upon down but it
is in fact in this position that Spassky
makes a terrible blunder like we've said
in the previous position f6 would have
been excellent here it's not all all
that much here nice characters on d4
would would have been best Bishop
captures and then f6 and the game
continues as possibly can leave at least
one minor piece on the board to keep
chances for pushing something more than
a draw because if Bishop captures
Spassky would improve his pawn structure
and would enjoy a much better position
but here after Fischer's nice the d4
Spassky actually plays f6
and f6 simply doesn't work because if
you take into consideration the Fisher's
previous move Knight to the d4 and you
take into consideration that this rope
is x-raying the undefended rockin c8 you
can see that f6 is a pretty big blunder
and it simply gives back the pawn so it
seems both players are already pretty
tired
it's game 14 official first blunders
that pawn he overlooks spassky's night
to see to remove attacking Fisher's
Queen and now
Spassky blunders this f6 move Fischer
simply captures at Bishop captures on f6
and there's no point in recapturing if G
captures Knight captures on b5 the rook
is unguarded and you you cannot
recapture back so white would be well
maybe not better but all of blacks
advantage is gone so Spassky tries a
different idea he played Bishop captures
on d4 and now comes a bunch of
characters on d4 the result is pretty
much the same and Knight captures pawn
captures it's five points each three
points island through a three point
islands each and there's no way to push
for anything here for the world champion
Boris Spassky it's a very strange how
this whole chess just a thing works
I look to b8 attacking the pawn and now
King to f1 even here Fischer makes the
absolute best move because now if you
start capturing pawns then a 5 is very
dangerous you can't capture of course
because you're getting checkmated here
so after a 5 you would have to move the
rook or something
for example f3 or make the make room for
the king and then after pawn captures
you would already have a rogue behind a
passed pawn and it would still be
manageable but you know you don't want
to give your opponent any chances so
after rook to b8 King to f1 I would have
rook capture some before Luke chapters
on c6 our rogue capture son before now
rook to a6 going after the a7 Ponder's
in the way to guard it our king of 7 row
captures and now after King f6 rook d7
was played now putting a rogue behind a
passed pawn
h5 who have kingi to g5 into e3
attacking the rock rookie for check King
moves a king attacks rook rook g7
to f6 rook d7 King e6 and it was in this
position on move 40 with what this move
King to e6 Spassky also reached tank
control that the players agreed to a
draw so it's really really a wonderful
game most likely not many of you have
seen it but really such such two amazing
moments in the game here after this
after Fischer went for this Bishop to b5
idea where he didn't want to guard this
pawn but it was a correct decision you
don't want to allow this attack so first
Fischer's blunder with this night to see
to remove he didn't see it he lost upon
but then very soon after this a couple
of moves then comes this f6 move i
Spassky an unbelievable move that very
hard very hard to believe that an na
1800 player would make such a move
because everyone can see that after
night to d4 the threat is Knight
captures and that the broken c8 is
unguarded so this is very hard very hard
to believe but I am it seems that all
this psychological warfare of the board
took took a really huge toll on Spassky
but on fischer as well as fischer also
made a very some very unbelievable
mistakes especially if he will consider
game 1 but yeah that's game 14 of the
1972 World Chess Championship match
between Robert James Fischer and Boris
cacilie its pasca I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Reavis James a
chance to bless key mark Carvalho's on
11e and end B Mitchell for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
video cereal for watching and I'll see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content and game 15 of the
match is definitely coming up thank you
all and I'll see you soon